everyone I'm Lucy I'm Tomo and we just
played a brand new build of Assassin's
Creed origins on the Xbox one X we're
out here at Gamescom so their big reveal
this time around was more of the story
exciting so we have factions new
characters a husband-and-wife duo that's
got the the potential for draw national
comedy so we have Ino he joins by a
husband and wife she is pledged to
Cleopatra yes who's upset that her
brother Ptolemy Ptolemy has basically
stolen the throne from her yeah so
basically Ptolemy and Cleopatra is dad
when he died was like okay you to trust
you birth to rule together yeah that
didn't happen things I might happen in
it yeah boy Caesar rolling up looking
for a Roman who Ptolemy has killed and
he's like don't killed him with the best
of intention he was like hey I killed
that guy you're looking for a psyche no
I wanted to do that myself and so he
aligns himself with Cleopatra so we did
a bunch of different diverse things like
I decided to follow the main quest to
start with yeah so we've been dropped
off in Memphis not as in like Elvis's
home no no Egypt and I'm facin Egypt and
you can't just dropped in and there's
like a main path you can follow or
there's just a ton of little side five
things here so you did the main one so
mine was the main quest and it was like
an investigation which kind of was a
refreshing change from the usual
Assassin's Creed stuff and it showed how
they were approaching these kind of
scenarios because then they've done
investigations in the past it reminded
me of the Jack the Ripper exactly so
like if you think of that as it's kind
of like the template it's very similar
so my the mystery was there's this
sacred ball which is being poisoned and
you need figure out how it is and you
use this kind of you pulse
essentially like eagle vision and
instead of like eagle vision hanging
around constantly
it just pings everything and it
highlights everything important so the
story was that after investigating some
I did some poop I put my hand in some
poop I found out that there the animal
was being poisoned by peach
features which are things but they're
bad for apparently but I turned out that
was that was being done by some twin
priestesses who were being forced to do
it by a mysterious group illuminating
order of some sort so then you find out
that they were there for hands was
forced by the order and that is because
their brother has been kidnapped and
thus begins kind of like the escapades
across the city
tracking down using your your trusty
eagle seenu to kind of scout out where
where the most likely place is that
where the brother is being held and you
kind of like traversing it's very dense
Memphis there is a lot going on there is
a lot going on and I don't know I wasn't
watching what you're doing but a various
points one of our Adam who's now manning
the camera was just wandering around the
city and at some point a hippo just
appeared like a bit close to the river
and just started a fight with him well I
turned away for a minute I turned back
an animal was flying a hippo and three
alligators and that's the kind of thing
that they're going for they don't want
like prescribed bottles they want this
emergent open world so we had the you
know kind of the idea that our they're
gonna be looking at Witcher for
inspiration and there is a bit of that
there you have this open world just
wander around and stuff will kind of pop
up and invite you to come and check it
out so when I was playing I did the main
mission as well but I also went to this
kind of like four things so if you go in
kill the leader loot the treasure and
it's basically just like a little little
activity to do them I've reminded me a
little bit of maybe like the Borgia
Towers
and that but then it was just mostly I
was sort of taking in how it's getting a
little more like far cry but in a good
way it's taking things from far cry so
it's a you know like liberation these
little mini outpost things animals kept
in cages that you can free and they can
wreak havoc so there was a lion and this
little fort and I was like don't worry
pal I got to get out there
Greeks and make some havoc at some guys
and put us you can if you get the
ability points you can like shame you
didn't tame these animals by putting
them to sleep first but then you contain
them yeah good morning that I was just
kind of wandering around and it's sort
of like you were saying it's just so
easy to get lost in things so there was
a cat I remember the the game director
ashraf saying that you can sort of
follow these characters around so I
found a cap and I followed him around
for a little bit yeah he's just art of
going he's going about his business and
then you know you can stay in Memphis
which is Reid ends a lot to do but we
can go out into the plains into the
desert that's what I did so I was like
there's a pyramid I'm gonna climb that
pyramid and run all the way to the
pyramid I said you can call a horse but
I decided to run just to check out the
park chorong and it's very similar a to
go up B to go down yes yeah so it's
simplified and it worked pretty well and
then I ran all the way to the pyramid
and climbed all the way up here yeah
it's really easy to do there's loads of
handholds whoever's building those
permits put in little handfuls just in
case some major I come on no one is at
the top got all the way through the top
and it wasn't a synchronization point
surprisingly I did find a
synchronization point but I didn't
realize that's what it was yeah it
doesn't synchronize anymore it kind of
refines his focus yes I think it's kind
of like putting more important things on
a map but in the actual pyramid I
climbed all the way to the top and
instead of just leaping off I leapt off
and then slide down the side which was
pretty cool and then I climbed back up
because it's actual tomb there and the
tomb was really cool because you go
inside and you do like a little
platforming section where you
into a convener and there's a puzzle
there it was a really simple puzzle but
it was like the weighted platform stuff
so you need to get to the other side and
there's loads of like objects in the
environment so you need to place them on
the right platform so that you can climb
up and jump over and at the end you get
to like the treasure area as you do in
the previous Assassin's Creed's and
usually like by reading one of the kind
of manuscripts around there you'll get
an ability point and a whole bunch of
crafting tools it's a nice little that
was a fairly early one too so I imagine
it's going to get a little more
complicated and they could even be like
stuff like you know dangers within their
traps and stuff so when I was going up
to one of the pots and I was hitting and
someone leaned over and said you want to
be careful because some of these have
snakes in them I know go buy one of
those yeah you go killed by a snake it
was a good moment where I was I was
escaping frustum from some gods and I
don't have in a pool and then I came up
and I said oh my god there's treasure
here great no there's a bloody snake why
does it always have to be safe so one of
the things that I'm really excited about
is kind of like this focus on the story
yeah it's you know ashes creed ballooned
in a quite spectacular fashion to the
point where we couldn't I couldn't tell
as a huge fan of the series what the
story was anymore but it's refocusing
now it's got byuk it's got I it's got a
couple of factions important like key
leaders from historical form historical
figures from you know the past and now
it's kind of telling a smaller tighter
story it seems and we get you know the
origins of the assassins via the Magi
the game's creep origins but for more
we're gonna have a ton of gameplay going
up because we both captured a lot so for
more on assassin's creed Argent's make
sure you keep your eyes peeled to
gamespot.com
and youtube.com slash games watch it
smash that subscribe button like your
MHO with a hammer
what you gain the pots again hit the
pots watch out the snakes on that
subscribe button and in the comments